what's going on guys welcome back to the
channel today we have this 2012
dodge charger and we're gonna program
new keys
for this car so this car uses
uh two different frequencies the 315
and the 420 35 i believe so
so as you can see these keys don't work
but we have the original right here that
works
so i already pre-selected my car we're
gonna select the dos charger
and we're gonna read the pin number
first
this car and for that we have to close
the switch
[Music]
and put the house hazards on so
i'm gonna select automatic detection
and now we're gonna wait by the way you
don't need wi-fi for this
you can be connected with the car and
having that
and not having wi-fi so let's just wait
and it should give me the the pin code
away
all right that's the password 4601
and now we're gonna go to contour
functions
and we're gonna select immobilizer smart
system
and for this i believe we have to have
the keys outside of the car
not close to the ignition switch because
we're gonna have interference so we're
gonna remove the original key
out
and another of this key out too
and just to make sure it doesn't detect
the keys we're gonna press
this and it says keynote detected so
we're good
and we're gonna work with one key first
so let's
select key learning
another key learning and it says turn
off
and turn the emergency flashers on
the flashers are on and we're gonna
place the key to be learned
and it says only place one key
inside to be learned in the vehicle and
the other keys
are gonna be outside so there's two keys
program
but we're gonna learn another one so we
press ok
and it's gonna ask for the pin number
which we already have
press ok all right and
as soon as it starts entering
it's gonna ask you to unlock
press the unlock and unlock
at the same time so let's do this until
we hear a peep
place this gear close to ignition
on the cup slot so we see here
we already programmed the key as you can
see
and it says if you want to learn another
key we press yes
and we take the other key that we had
we put the other one away
on the roof and then
it says remove the current key prepare
another kit we program
in the car slot so we press okay
and we're gonna see the same
same screen we had so we press
the unlock press okay
and i heard the locks right away
so we have four keys already programmed
and now
we just press no because we already
finished
we exit this and now we turn off the
hazards
and let's see if the key opens the
switch
as you can see and it opens the switch
let's see if it turns on and it turns on
guys
so this is how you program the keys for
a 2012
dos charger and if you have the remote
store
it's the same thing challengers pretty
much all of them
work the same so i hope you liked the
video
please if you haven't subscribed to the
channel subscribe
like comment down below dislike if you
didn't like the video
and i'll see you on the next video guys
[Music]
[Applause]
bye